and when i heard a definition
that
humility and being humble is about
admitting and knowing that you have more
to learn i went oh now that i can
purchase let's go back to that moment in
new york whitney's with her aggressive
lover i'm in i'm in new york i'm
crawling around on the ground not
knowing crying not knowing if i'm gonna
vomit not knowing what i'm gonna do and
i
i ask the universe for help
one thing that's a benefit because i
rarely ask the universe for help and
it's not because i don't need help i
just it's not something that i do so
putting me to the point where i asked
for help
already one major benefit sure of that
moment right like like it's just being
like yo i just can't i need help like
source universe god whatever your
vocabulary permits like i need help so i
think these moments in my life i really
reflect
and i start to ask myself why am i this
way why do i feel this way after a
situation after i'm succeeding after i'm
failing after a breakup whatever it is
why
that's where my biggest lessons come the
best thing you can do is figure out what
it is that's actually different about
you and run with it
i could not agree with you more that's
what i tell my kids all the time you're
saying it i wish they were all listening
you young broadway boot campers if
you're listening to this danica just
said what i say all the time man if you
if you can take that ball to the end
game and love it
do it
like nobody gets input and if you can do
it with a weird run
do it you know do it i'm 4 11.
i have this unique speaking voice
you know i'm sure that in at times in my
career it has not served me but mostly
it has served me well because it's made
me different
and i've accepted that i sound like
betty boop and i've accepted that i
can't see over most counters and i've
accepted the things about me that were
made fun of i learned
towards the end of my career that the
things that drained me weren't for me
and the things that gave me energy were
definitely in alignment and it didn't
even mean that the workload was the same
it could have been like minuscule
amounts of things that i didn't want to
do that would be like exponentially
draining and then on the other side it
could be something that was a high
volume amount of work
work
but it energized me and left me feeling
almost high from it and you're you know
you start to realize how important the
things when things are in alignment
and i think that you know that was a
lesson i learned first let's just unpack
the fact that you've just dropped
probably the most important lesson in
life
which is that your body
has intelligent design
and it is constantly sending you signals
and when something shrinks you depletes
you makes you feel like you're hiding
uh
that is a
hugely important signal to pay attention
to and one of the simple secrets in life
is
spend more time
with people and doing experiences
that expand you or energize you and you
also said something important it has
nothing to do with whether or not
something is easy
or something is difficult and has
everything to do
with the kind of energy that you feel
when you're either in that experience or
you are with
those people that are meant for you and
so that's number one there is a whole
bucket of [ __ ]
that i will never write about because
it's
too awful
but when i say
that i am optimistic and when i say that
i keep choosing joy even when it's hard
and when i say that um
like
i can see how things are for me
i hope that people at this point at
least the people who read my books
understand that i'm not just talking out
of one side of my mouth i'm not it's
it's very easy to look at my life now
and sort of
you know um
be flippant about like oh well easy for
you to say you're a successful author or
like i understand
that i will never truly understand
the full privilege of
being a white woman of
having the access that i have of now
getting to a place where i have
financial resources that i didn't have
but what
people can understand or not is that i
grew up poor
i grew up in a shitty
hard
home life
i moved away from home at 17 like moved
to a different city at 17 like wasn't
even old enough to
lease my own apartment because i just
wanted to escape i wanted to get away
and i remember
when
for for all of high school
that i just kept thinking
like i'm going to get out of here i'm
going to get out of here i'm going to
get is all i thought about was all i
focus on it's probably the original like
me goal setting is like going back to
those teenage years
and it was all i thought about was just
getting away from this house i just
wanted to be out of this house i wanted
to be out of this environment because i
kept telling myself
if you leave this place
and you're still unhappy then you will
know that it's you i smoked when i drank
uh and then it became a habit every day
all day and uh so my mom smoked too and
she died of lung cancer and um and i
talked to her about that you know
but it put a fear in me
that
um
man i don't know how much time i got
left maybe it's
20 years maybe it's 40 years who knows
but
i'm going you know it made me really
realize i guess how precious uh life is
but it that impacted me
and made me um
you know made me really
try to
enjoy
my girls and and and appreciate what i
have my marriage
um
but yeah i don't know it
it still bothers me now i mean it was
recent so i'm still not quite sure
you know that i'm that i'm through the
through the woods but uh
that i can still stand head high heart
height shoulders back look you in the
eye and carry forward and understand
that i've built things in my life and
i'm carrying them with me and let's go
courageously into the future
um but until i got that little click of
what that word meant
[Music]
you know
my relationship spiritually was
sort of on and off on and off a little
bit more um
i do i've also also found this this is
another metaphor for i think not only my
relationship spiritually but a lot of
people's
i found that when i
put other things like my career
or or or you know uh
if when that's not the top of the ladder
that's not the number one
thing of my what i've got to achieve
when it moves down to two or three
behind say family and faith
i'm better at it
and then i received some help and i
received a message that came through
at that moment and the message was the
sun does not judge itself by the shadows
that it casts
if i'm the sun
i don't need to judge myself
by the effect that my light is having
you know so like the shadows that are
cast so
my how much
she
wants me or how much i'm affecting her
how much she's thinking about me those
are all the shadows that my light is
casting you know it's like that's not
how i need to judge myself that's not
how i need to decide whether i'm the sun
like the sun doesn't look at that person
they sunburn it's like [ __ ] yeah i'm the
sun like i burned that person you know
are like oh yeah i'm the sun i created
that desert oh i'm the sun i created
that beautiful beach environment like
it's just the sun
it is just being the sun
and so that lesson came from an extreme
circumstance
so that point of resistance became
assistance and that became something
that
was this focal point for me
understanding the true nature of who i
was which is not judging myself by the
effects that i'm having on the world but
judging myself
by purely who i am the essence of who i
am
which is you know you can call it light
or you can call it energy you call it
source you call it love you know and
really love i think is the best way to
describe the essence of who we are we're
love embodied and when i take full
responsibility for everything my parents
my the sexual abuse the losses the wins
the breakups whatever the good the bad
when i take ownership for it all
even if i didn't actually do it but if i
take responsibility i feel so much peace
because i don't have anyone else to
blame
i just accept it i don't say it's okay
yeah that these things happen but i say
okay it's happened and i've accepted it
what can i learn from this where's the
good in this and how can i move forward
and that's what brings me a lot of peace
i don't know i i
i came out of dad's passing and just
[Music]
i got wild and
clubby
yeah we we raised hell and had fun and
we raced and we tried to do everything
we could just to
keep marching forward
and
and you know and then
you know
ended up having a pretty reasonable
time and and success in racing and and
then like i said just recently my mom
passed and it sort of reset the stage if
you will
like what's important in life and and
damn you better
appreciate what you got while you're
here and
um
you know be everything you can to
the these two little girls that i got
and
um try to be a good husband and
you know
just uh enjoy it golly because it's
short as hell
it's not your environment it's not these
people you will for the rest of your
life have to take responsibility for the
fact that it's you
and
i remember that as a teenager saying
like right now
i'm in this environment and i think that
that's why life is so
can i cuss on the show i've already come
once okay
right now like i think that their why
life is so shitty but if i get out of
here
and i'm still
miserable
then i will know that it was just
geography
it didn't it doesn't matter if i have a
bad attitude if i'm negative if i'm
the if i'm this way then it won't matter
where i move and it won't matter how
much money i make and it won't matter
who i know or who my friends are i will
always be this way and so in in that
awareness
i i remember moving to la and working
three jobs and
just all i want to do is survive just
live in this little crappy apartment and
survive away from that home life
and i would have days where it would
like oh my gosh you know i would be
overwhelmed or it would be hard and i'll
be like nope
nope
remember
where you come from and remember what it
felt like and at least this might be
this crappy apartment in hollywood and
you might only be able to shop at the 99
cent store but you own this life
nobody gets to come into your space
nobody gets to yell at you nobody gets
to make you feel less than like you get
to own this
and a
a hard existence that you choose for
yourself
beats
anything that's that someone else forces
on you because at least
from my perspective at least then you're
in control
okay i'm from the bible belt i'm a
christian i have certain beliefs how
does that fit into
who you are in show business well i
decided when i was young and i think it
was
mature decision i don't know how i knew
this maybe god
i went okay
i'm gonna be me
and it's not gonna be pretty and happy
and perfect for everybody but i'm just
gonna go ahead and be me because
i can't i can't do anything else
and i think it's dolly parton that says
be you because everybody else is taken
and it's a great piece of advice
she even says something to go further
she says
um find out who you are
and do it on purpose i'm like that's
what i said in my 20s i learned that and
i'm glad i learned that young